a bunch of kids are like making fun of
me like why is your mom say your name
weird and I was offended a little bit I
was acting and singing in my first
musical play I noticed that my mom was
sitting right in the restricted front
row very yet she wasn't allowed to do
that but I mean I loved it I remember my
teachers said that I was doing really
bad in history and it was just very
embarrassing to you because I had to
translate that to my mom there was this
time that the dryer broke and in my dad
it likes to fix everything but he goes
to the store and comes home and he tells
me I need to don't miss that I'm like
dad I don't know there's no staff and he
talks to the guy again and then I'm like
you wanted a thermostat this whole time
he was like sometimes you just have to
try to understand what I'm saying the
telemarketer they'd come
she'd say hey come talk to them and I
would stand on the phone I find out that
they're trying to convince me like a you
know 7 to 8 year old trying to sell me
insurance and I don't know how to
respond to that every afternoon my mom
would walk my brother and I down to the
park in our community this little girl
started kicking sand in my direction my
mom without touching her she puts her
hand over her legs and she just says
stop she ran off there were four or five
big women pushing each other out of the
way grabbing each other by the shoulder
saying let me get a piece let me get a
piece of her my mom just sort of stood
there like why are you talking to me I
don't know what's going on I said in
front of her eight-year-old me and like
and I just did this with my hands to
protect my mom there were all these
horrific things that were being said to
my mom and I had to translate all of
that I lost it
I was crying and I you know standing
behind her holding onto her shirt soon
enough boom punch straight to the face
because her priorities were always work
work worked in order to survive she had
no time and energy to dedicate to
learning English
when it comes to shame I feel like not
only do they feel it but I get the first
wave of that shame having to hear things
like well why don't your parents be
English you know while your dad or your
mom were here in the background saying
things like oh that lady she didn't
treat us very well you know she spoke
like she was very mean since I was a
young child trying to help translate for
my parents people always had this idea
that I didn't have the capabilities
understanding what the conversation was
about
and I know that when I was you know
younger I'd I'd get so frustrated asking
my parents mom can you help me write a
sentence I'm sorry Mia I don't I don't
know how to do that go ask your dad okay
dad can you help me write a sentence
I'm sorry mija I don't know how to do
that she came home from work and she was
like acting very frustrated and and I
was like mom like what's what's up and
she's like you know so you don't
understand I was like what what do you
mean mom is just like I'm stupid I just
I'm slow I'm uneducated that's how like
I knew like my biggest regret in my
entire life is that I didn't teach my
mom more English when I was a kid my dad
was a veteran film war my parents had to
flee the country so every time I have to
translate for them as I think about why
do I even have to do that and it's
because they sacrificed so much to be
here for me
you
now that I'm older I feel like they need
to learn English knowing more than I
should know about my parents as a
younger kid makes me feel much more
capable to take care of them when
they're older I just want to tell my
parents how much I'm grateful for them
regardless of sometimes this force
responsibilities of having to be there
and translating for them it's the least
I can do to repay them for all their
sacrifices mommy come to mine you in
them it means I love you mom very much
you
you